[Musique]
un geste qui n'avait pas été posé depuis
des décennies 70 ans après sa mère
Charles III a été couronné roi
d'Angleterre
l'orbe du souverain la couronne de
Saint-Édouard ses héritages du 17e
siècle rappelle à quel point cette
cérémonie est ancrée dans la tradition
et pour ce couronnement Charles III a
voulu ajouter quelques nouveautés
des champs gospel ont par exemple été
interprété chef de l'Église ambigane le
roi a aussi invité les représentants
d'autres confessions pratiquées au
Royaume-Uni elle aussi couronnée la
femme du roi est officiellement devenue
la reine Kamila dans l'abbaye un public
réduit plus de 8000 personnes avaient
été invitées en 1953 ils étaient environ
2200 aujourd'hui des membres de famille
royale du monde entier des dirigeants
politiques mais aussi des représentants
d'associations caritatives dans le
carrosse royal couvert d'or les
souverains sont retournés vers le palais
de Buckingham sur le tracé un public que
la pluie londonienne n'a pas découragé
autre tradition la famille royale est
apparue sur le balcon du palais autour
du roi deux grands absents son fils
Harry et son frère Enzo tous deux
étaient présents au couronnement mais ce
sont faits très discrets
malgré les controverses qui ont secoué
la monarchie britannique ces dernières
années ces royalistes subsistent
optimistes
j'espère qu'il aura un long règne et
qu'il prendra soin du pays ajoute-t-il
la majorité des Britanniques ne me
rattacher à la monarchie un appui qui
selon des sondages à toutefois diminuer
au cours des 10 dernières années
les républicains ont profité du
couronnement pour faire entendre leur
revendications certaines d'entre eux ont
été arrêtés des pancartes ont été saisis
[Musique]
est mal distribuée dans ce pays la
famille royale en est l'illustration
qui aura lieu au château de Windsor en
soirée après les célébrations le nouveau
souverain devra faire face à son lot de
défi depuis le dernier couronnement il y
a 70 ans la relation avec la Couronne a
bien changé dans plusieurs pays du
commonwalt tout comme ici au Royaume-Uni
ici rappelle Bouvier Auclair
Radio-Canada